andrew what is your middle name i really
want to clarify this in the worst way
i do not have a middle name uh the the
internet has sometimes given me one
um but i do not have a legal middle name
i eventually asked my parents hey i
don't have a middle name why is that and
my mom said
because we wanted you to choose one i
never did actually choose one
and so it's andrew yang legally
everything else is just a you know
made-up thing
so if you have the power to control
andrew yang's wikipedia page it says
andrew m yang that is [ __ ] we don't
know where the m came from do we know
what that m stands for
i thought i thought it was middle name
man i literally think that someone
andrew the man
took them took middle name and took a
name
thank you thank you wikipedia photo
[Music]
chooser
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks your co-host
zach grauman
guys folks it is officially
our 100th episode of yank speaks or
officially when we're celebrating it
we thought it'd be fun to bring back a
little zach and andrew banter
and do a little mailbag we haven't done
it in a while so you guys asked
i put it out there on the podcast ask
ask yangspeaks
i got a whole bunch of questions i'm
just going to ask andrew a whole bunch
of them see how many we get to
and get some good old yang takes because
you all know that's why you're here
so guys happy 100th episode if you've
listened to all 100
i applaud you thank you from the bottom
of my heart i
never thought anyone would think uh
andrew or myself are that interesting to
listen to us talk
at 100 different times we're excited we
love doing it and this episode is a fun
one so tune in we're doing a little
mailbag
great mailbag episode of yang speak
starting right now
[Music]
hello everyone and when i say everyone i
really mean zack
zack it's back and why is it a reunion
it's a reunion because
it's approximately the hundredth episode
of yank speaks
i think technically it's something like
104th but who's counting it's a
celebration of it i
just want to say thank you to everyone
who's listening and been here with us
from the beginning or from the middle or
end whatever um really appreciate it
love you all and i am so pumped to
answer some questions that were sent by
some of the folks who have been with us
the whole time um so zach and i are
going to dig
in but first uh zach missed you man i
mean heck
uh yeah so wow man i know it's it's been
too long
um i hope people missed it out there in
the world too because you know me and
zach had a little bit of staggered
casting duties where like i'd be on
monday with someone
that zach would be on thursday with two
someones and then i would show up
and then you might have been out there
thinking like did andrew and zach
break up do they hate each other
um i i don't know if anyone is actually
thinking that i have no idea but
still man still going no now they're
thinking it but of course the fact that
we're hanging out
uh right right now would uh disabuse
anyone of that thought
um but i have missed you i have missed
this uh and this time instead of
discussing
uh specific current events in the way
that we have in the past instead we're
gonna answer some questions
everybody who used the hashtag
askgangspeaks first of all thank you
um it was fun to read through so let's
dive in man let's have some fun we'll do
some policy we'll do some tech stuff
we'll do
some fun stuff so here's my first
question we got this a lot
um but this is from k rosis um at
k-a-y-r-o-s-i-s
says 2018 og yang gang here thank you
for that
how has your diagnosis of what's wrong
with america
changed since you wrote your book the
one normal people
and what would you have done differently
if you knew this in 2018
i love this question a bunch of you
asked it yang what are your thoughts
well we are living a version of the
future that i'd feared
back in 2018 and i just want to thank
you keirosis love you
but i remember when zach went through
the war on normal people it's one of the
things that caused him to quit his job
and uh join up to run the campaign
and we are living a version of that
future are we not
one thing that came out just today was
that
our job numbers have been very very
disappointing
in terms of people coming back i think
they expected a million
and got something like 270 000
that's kind of a big miss and then also
an earlier number i saw got revised down
from something like 700 000 also like
276
000. um so the jobs numbers are really
really bad
we're still missing 8.2 million people
are saying hey it's because unemployment
benefits are so high
uh i don't think that's the cause of
majority of this like maybe at the very
margins it might be doing something
frankly shootings and crime have spiked
in environments around the country
mental health has gotten absolutely
crushed i mean some of the numbers i saw
said that over half of people are
suffering from some kind of
anxiety or depression or mental illness
a lot of kids have been suffering from
learning loss in a particular way
uh it's it's bad um now
if you were to ask me what i would have
done differently if i knew this in 2018
i mean shoot if i'd be able to see the
pandemic coming i mean then i probably
would have dropped everything and just
kind of been like hey
instead of warning people about the
automation wave i would have been like
there's going to be a pandemic
that we could get in front of that it's
been
at least on some level somewhat
encouraging that
the policy responses at the federal
level have kept growing
in size and scope uh you know this
child poverty tax credit could be a game
changer for millions of families i don't
think it gets enough press
if you look into it uh it's going to
send the equivalent of 300
a month to millions maybe even tens of
millions of families
uh clearly the stimulus checks were the
most popular thing
in the rescue plan and the other relief
acts where
something like 85 percent of americans
liked it
and i was always very firm in the belief
that if we started putting cash in
people's hands
people were going to love it and people
are going to see that it worked it's the
best thing that we do and then they're
going to want more of it
and i i very much believe that we're on
that path everything you thought about
didn't change just actually started
moving faster which is dark
um let me ask you this i've seen
mcdonald there's i mean this means
i don't know the numbers on this you
just and you just kind of touched on it
talking about this on the margins
mcdonald's offering
50 bucks an interview and things like so
the low-paying jobs companies are
struggling to fill
um and i think you've known that when
you talk about universal basic income
you're like yeah the jobs that are
horrific on people either need to pay
them more or they need to automate fast
because it's
human suffering in some ways
exploitation um
but there's probably a transition period
between the full ubi
and then like this like gap of
employment with those types of jobs like
thoughts on
how you help companies and people make
that transition
that's a great question i do think in
some of those cases i mean you do just
need to compensate more yeah
so some of these businesses agreed um
you totally do it
uh i don't think that's a bad thing i
think if people had a certain level of
subsistence and then
uh weren't getting exploited and then
could actually make a choice whether
they wanted or didn't want a job and
then
if the company wanted them to work they
need to maybe pay them more
give them better benefits you know like
i i think that's
positive the problem really is the
transition
and it's one of the reasons why i really
tried to
go through in my book like what the
steps could look like because there's
this real disease in american life
certainly in the media
where everyone just goes okay point a
point b like we're gonna go
here here and you know and then you're
like well what about that incredibly
long
or brutal or disruptive interim period
that will probably last
x years um so if you think about
this situation with fast food workers
like what would my preference be either
pay people
significantly more or automate the jobs
uh
and then the the problem right now is
this interim period where you have
businesses that are like oh
i actually can't pay you more but and we
can't automate these jobs and so like
what do we do
and you know and and then now people are
complaining it's like oh people
won't accept my shitty like
you know uh sub subsistence uh wage to
do this job
so we're we're in a period of mammoth
transition the fact that the labor
market numbers are so bad
um is a sign that this transition is not
going that well and one of the things
that i've always been very very afraid
of which is one reason i was pushing so
hard for cash relief this whole time
is that our government is such an
imperfect administrator of trying to
uh make people whole or right the wrong
so you had like these ppp programs and
you know i'm so glad that they exist but
like you got to know that there's been
some really bananas
inequities in terms of like who gets the
ppp what they use it for
like there are some business owners who
just access money and then you know
frankly like
certainly didn't preserve jobs as a
result and then if you're less plugged
in then you're much less likely to get
that aid
so it's one reason why i was so
passionate about cash relief is like
well at least they can know that you
exist
you know if you exist you get money free
money if you plug in
right yeah yeah and it was chamath uh
palapatiya who said look we should just
be trying to make people whole and like
let these companies and their capital
structures uh you know figure it out
and that was a very interesting point
the issue is that
we've said look let's make these
institutions whole because it will help
the people
but then it's only the people that are
connected to the institutions that
get protected and get made whole and i
saw this versions of this
um in the questions was the economy is
like like a flywheel like a huge wheel
and once it's spinning it's on it's
almost unstoppable
you know things do stop it but when it
stops it takes a lot to get it started
um is cash relief the best lubricant to
get that thing kick-started
um or thoughts like on the federal level
that excite you both from the byte
administration or that they're not doing
like what else do you think i agree with
you in the like cash like we've always
agreed on that like
that needs to be you got a mindset of
buttons you gotta get people plugged in
um but other things you think would um
help get us out of this hole mark cuban
had an idea i quite
liked um which is he wanted money that
was kind of used or lose it like you got
to spend it within the week or it's gone
you know um you know and then i
suggested something that's like maybe
just at locally owned small businesses
and like you know he wasn't a huge fan
of that uh edition but like i think
there's something about kind of
simulating activity um and and cash is
uh the the best thing but it could even
be improved on in a particular way i was
thinking about for example let's say
travel
like what would get you to travel again
and certainly having money might help
you travel
um but maybe some crazy deal on like a
travel thing might help you travel
or like you know what i mean like uh
like it might be possible to subsidize
some of the things that would generate
activity malta is paying tourists up to
240 bucks 200 euros
to travel to their country see malta
like this is what i'm talking about
you know what i mean like if you're
going to generate activity you got to
kind of be like the maltese
you know i i think our friend pete
boudijedge his family might be from
malta i think that might be right really
yeah i think that might be right to me
it's like we've all
over the past year become these
creatures of internal
almost laziness right um where it's
you're getting your food delivered your
groceries deliver your streaming your
social activities are all in
online or non-existent and we need to
start incentivizing people just
physically get out of their places and
physically um
get up and at them so i love the concept
of like food trucks and like
hey the food's cheap or free
incentivized if you but you have to get
out of your apartment they don't deliver
right
things like that i don't know wow look
at that yeah i think rewarding proximity
is a really powerful and interesting
idea
at kitty underscore m underscore welch
thank you for the question asked the
best affordable housing solutions you've
seen nationwide which i agree is like
the other piece of poverty here and
homelessness around the country who is a
tough issue and accelerating this
pandemic for sure
what are your thoughts one of the the
big innovations i have seen is that they
have
come a long way in modular housing it's
not suitable in every
environment the biggest thing that
that i've seen in like some specific
locations
has been 3d printed houses now i got to
say the 3d printed houses that i have
seen
were not great
because you are like oh yeah this thing
but um but in terms of time
built and cost it was fascinating
um so shipping containers modular
housing uh 3d printed housing
all have some serious potential uh i've
seen
dwellings that the average person would
be
pretty satisfied with that that can be
built for uh
you know 30 50 60 80
000 in some cases and it's very
attractive
not to say that things need to be low
cost but
those are the things that came to mind
when you ask like about affordable
housing
solutions nationwide one of the trends
i've found is community living is an
easy is a fun way to share costs and
make sure
yes i'm a huge fan of like communal
living i think there should be more
experiments in communal living
you know i'm going to share something
that i read a while ago that
um some people relate to um so emil and
i have been attracted to communal living
or communes for a while really when you
have kids in particular you're like wow
kids are a lot of work i
sure wish that we had like more people
that we could like maybe
have our kids play with their kids maybe
we take care of their kids they take
their markets whatever it is
but apparently when you look at com
communal living and communes and commune
culture
there's like a particular period during
which the culture can remain very very
positive but then it starts to veer
towards the negative in a particular
period of time
and that period of time has actually
been measured people have studied it
but i the the number in my mind is
something like seven years it's
imprecise but like the principle is
there
that um that apparently like the
cultures
of these kinds of environments can be
very very positive but then tend to
be hard to maintain
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by hello tushy
yes we're still doing bidet
ads on this podcast and there's no other
bidet you want to talk about then hello
tushy you cut down
on toilet paper which adds up by the way
if you have to if you're an adult you're
buying your own toilet paper that stuff
adds up it also clogs your toilet so you
have to worry about that
it's better for the environment and some
people particularly myself they love
them it's easier it's better
so the brand new 3.0 hello tushy modern
bidet
is awesome it's eco-friendly it's
stylish easy to install and it cleans
itself it's pretty freaking cool all
water so here's the deal
get your booty in gear folks get a bidet
go to hellotushy.com
yang to get 10 off plus free shipping we
love doing these because there's
discount so 10 off
and free shipping pretty great special
offer just for yang speaks listeners go
to hellotushy.com
yang for 10 off hellotushy.com
yang
[Applause]
so water bamboo tray 1 says are you
invested in dogecoin
and a water bamboo tray one i regret to
say i am not
invested in dogecoin uh you know i just
haven't been on top of a lot of things
on that side
uh but if you are it's had a great run
so congrats
and uh i'm happy for it because i think
people are calling it
um the people's crypto and amen to that
um the future of crypto what i'm excited
about is ideally more people getting
access to money and
more access to assets not just cash
because it can grow
ideally faster and and more um
how much uh
this is dr sefrin at doctor underscore
seferim
how much sleep do you lose regretting
your betrayal of the knicks
the answer to dr serafim is i don't lose
any sleep
because if if i had been a hardcore fan
over these last number of years
i would have been so miserable and
now that they're doing well i'm happy
for them i'm happy for them the way you
are happy for like an ex-girlfriend
uh who you see doing well and you're
like oh i'm glad but it's not like
you've been
you know living and dying with their
well-being uh for the last number of
years so it feels really great it feels
really healthy
i'm still very happy for every knicks
fan um if you've been through them this
last number of years you deserve every
bit of success
and they are very likable well-coached
team now
uh they've got some really rootable
players uh they've got a very bright
future
it's it's an exciting time to be an
expand so congrats to
to those uh who are in that boat uh but
no i don't really
sleep hey would you consider taking your
ex-girlfriend the knicks back if james
dolan
wasn't the the owner like it was or is
that a deal
okay no no if if james dolan wasn't the
owner i would take a long look
for sure anyone who's a die-hard sports
fan yeah like i i felt
i felt this with the bills i was pretty
close they eventually got a new owner um
um the sabers are a disaster for me so
like i still have
the same owner but i'm a little
disappointed i get that because it's
tough to pour your heart and soul into
something when you're just like they'll
never win because of this so
maybe two no no no jim dolan his defense
he doesn't have one of those types of
owners it's like he is willing to spend
which frankly in that
context is one of the most important
ingredients
um so it's not like one of the other
types of owners that will just totally
like you know
uh like their play thing right saw a
team for spare parts or whatever and
like trying to puppeteer in that way
he's not one of those
there are a lot of knicks fans that can
relate to me on this i know it and
i i was um perhaps even more attached to
jeremy little insanity than some other
fans but i know a lot in expands that
when uh jeremy lin left they were just
like uh
you know like down to the dumps and it
took them a while to recover it's just
in my case you know like i i i
had a breakup experience oh this is one
i've actually been curious we haven't
really fleshed out to so
at ls underscore progress for all
tweeted out a four day work week would
help many of our problems overworking
lack of jobs carbon footprint
mental health but even though andrew
supports it he doesn't seem to be
prioritizing
it why is that and i don't like i
that's i don't know if you're fair to
say you're not prioritizing but i guess
it has been front of mind for you
all the time thoughts on four day work
week and how would you actually get that
done is that a that's a president of the
country thing how does that work
thank you for the question i certainly
love the four day work week
i do think it would actually really help
us right now you know a lot of people
are stressed out in the zoom era
we could use some more jobs uh it it
would
help the environment and
the the reason why i think you know
maybe i haven't been
uh talking about it uh of late is that
it does strike me as like a very big
national issue priority where you know
like
if you could legislate it at some level
at the federal level then you can really
start to move things
but this has made me reflect on the fact
that there may be other things in other
environments that could help move this
forward
because i'm a huge believer i think a
four-day work week really could help
bring us back from the brink
many things where the average work week
just keeps getting longer and longer
that may not even include all the
always-on and remote time and the rest
of it
and a four-day work week could give us
the genuine balance so thank you
ls progress for all uh because i'm all
about it
uh man maybe we can do something more
anyone listening to this organizations
can do it i don't know if you remember
the zak we had this conversation
where with humanity forward we were like
hey you know how we're all for a four
day work week
oh yeah we want to try to do a four-day
work week
at hf and then we did it
and then it seemed to work great like
hopefully we can make it so everyone
gets a long weekend
oh my gosh would life be better for all
of us that would be great um
all right cool i had a good ubi question
that i thought was fun uh at fansharius
said should ubi be a percentage of gdp
divided by the number of opt-in
participants rather than a fixed amount
so you would adjust
the amount you're giving in your
universal basic income wage
by the number of people opting in as
percent of gdp thoughts on that i
thought it was interesting
ban share us there were a number of
proposals that i looked through but
before i ran for president on like what
the ubi proposal should look like
and so some people were thinking about
like hey how about you take
um like a carbon tax and you're like
divided by
number of people and we get this much
money or there are different
natural resources that we could use in
this case you're saying percentage of
gdp
and the reason i just went straight for
a thousand a month is that it would be
impossible to explain to anyone like hey
you're going to get x and it's going to
be range and like no one knows the rest
of it i'm just like screw it
let's just give them like you know a
number that everyone can understand it's
a thousand a month
um and so i did that for political
reasons like
in terms of policy is that wiser um
i personally think that making a
commitment to people that they can
understand and that you're then on the
hook for and then
you know you we work with that is a
better approach
because um though i will say that
obviously alaska's had a fairly positive
experience with the alaska oil dividend
which is
petroleum money divided by number of
alaskans et cetera et cetera so
um they get a range in any given year so
they don't know what it's going to be
i think of late it is ranged from maybe
something like 800 to 1500
a year per person so it's like a
significant range
um and it hasn't been the end of the
world so maybe there is something to
like uh uh some kind of total divided by
number of people that that could work
fine just like it did in alaska but
i thought for political reasons and
communication reasons uh you just want
to set a number
to me there's something to be said for
um some of these benefits particularly
cash relief or anything really
flying under the radar you know because
like when it's front and center you're
like 1000
a month for everybody if you were
president right now there'd be the
republicans lining up to stop that right
you'd be freaking out
but right now under the buy
administration there are
it's not a thousand dollars a month but
essentially with some of these childhood
tax credits that are being front loaded
there are families getting a form of a
ubi right now
or are going to be soon which is
exceptional i'm very proud of that i
think we had something to do with that
um and it's not dragged in the media
whatsoever because it's kind of
complicated and it's a little bit
under the rug between infrastructure and
other things you're talking about in
climate change you know what i'm saying
in this case too it was also somewhat
bipartisan zach because some republicans
are for it it's very pro-family
and because it's pro-family i don't
think it ever will be dragged you know
like the the child tax credit actually
increases for a number of kids you have
which republicans really like because
then it's like oh you're more kids you
get a bit more money you can like raise
them better
uh and democrats obviously should love
it so i think it's going to be
um one of those rare rare unicorns where
like no one
particularly wants to attack the child
poverty tax credit
all right this is a good one um and i
know something you're passionate about
tembo ghost 1989 thank you timbo ghost
i'd like to ask you all how do we break
down the widespread lies and
misinformation in our society so much
human energy human energy is wasted lost
and misguided through people being
misled
and tricked you know we agree with that
um we have tristan harris on here too
talking about
a a point of this disinformation or
kevin ruth stop about we had a number of
guests talk about
um thoughts yeah so some of you know
that i
am working on a book uh it's going to be
out um
toward the end of this year but it tries
to break down some of the reasons why
we're all just
freaking trying to figure out what's
true and not true and like our society
just can't agree on anything and you're
seeing it again with things around
the vaccine and other things that we
should hopefully be able to
come together on um so the three things
i i
identified are local news
cable news and social media as all being
problematic now local news is
problematic in that it's
dying like i actually think local news
is one of the antidotes
but 2000 newspapers have gone out of
business and they were local papers
and local papers tend to be more down
the middle i mean first like
if there's like you know a new um bridge
being installed in your town there's not
really like that much of a partisan spin
you know what i mean you know it's like
or the high school team
like how's it doing it's like oh like
you know like you're not really
uh trying you know the reporter usually
you see him at the bar you see him at
the kid's soccer game whatever it is
right there's a certain level of
accountability
instead of this like national figure
right in op-eds absence of local
journalism
has been shown to make it so people just
vote along party lines which makes
polarization worse which is obvious like
if you don't know what the hell is going
on like of course you're just gonna be
like ah
and this like show up and vote for
whomever but some of the the deeper
things act that i saw were just
mind-boggling like um people run for
office less because like who cares no
one's covering it anyway
uh the cost of municipal bonds goes up
because people just don't care as much
and it's like kind of corrupt
so like so it just goes to show
local journalism kind of thing kind of
important
um and we had a talk with elizabeth
green of chalkbeat a little while ago
about this so if you're really into this
issue you can go check it out
um the second thing is that cable news
just becomes so ridiculously polarized
um where you have these networks that
are just
very openly um catering to certain
audiences
uh and just giving them more of what
they want ideologically
and just separating us out from each
other
so when when we're running for president
zach you know i did so much cable news
in part because it's one of the only
games in town like let's say you're
a candidate trying to get uh some
attention it's like well you have like
network news programs it's like
they're not going to have you on them at
most they might have you on once you
know and then if they had you on once
then you're not going to be back for a
while whereas cable news they're going
to have different programs like in the
same channel you're going to be able to
build
24 hours of content man they've got 24
hours of content to fill like network
news maybe has like an hour
to or something like that and so um and
so
you wind up with people being in
somewhat
uh ideological echo chambers uh through
cable news
um and then the third the biggest
culprits obviously like social media
just
you know making it so that everything is
questioned conspiracy theories are
uh rampant and attract millions of
adherents
um so this is a very long-winded way of
answering when something when timbogo
says hey you look at all these problems
uh the immediate fixes in my mind are
invest in local journalism and there's
actually a law in congress called the
local journalism sustainability act that
believe or not would put billions of
dollars into
helping newspapers survive and other
types of publications but primarily
newspapers
give everyone a tax credit for getting a
local new subscription
giving businesses a tax credit for
advertising in the paper it's like it's
really good stuff
um and i for the life of me have no idea
why congress has not passed it because
red states are losing their papers just
like blue states i mean like look around
and being like do you really
not want a town paper in your town i
mean like like that's not should not be
a partisan issue
um and and the the local journalism
sustainability act is just like tax
credits and other things that's like not
going to affect the nature of the
information
on the cable news side i would
bring back the fairness doctrine which
is when back in the day when you
were supposed to show two sides of a
political issue
which you know people would hem and han
scream bloody murder but
frankly i think media was more rational
um pre
uh 1987 or whenever that that rule uh
died and i'm old enough to vaguely
remember news from that era
it was very boring it was just like you
know people are saying the same stuff
like
would you be the worst thing in the
world it should be medicine
let people entertain elsewhere that's my
thought yes
and in social media so social media my
my proposal in this direction
is that uh it needs to be ad free like
we just make this thing ad free and
that that would help a lot um so you
know
contrast something like netflix and
youtube
um where netflix is serving your content
but it's
ad free and you can pay for it it's a
wild garden um
and then youtube it's just like kind of
like you know just
because yeah like you know it's got to
go down that rabbit hole
um and so that that now these would be
massive changes
i think that they would help and then
even after you do all of these things
tembo ghost
it still wouldn't really do the trick it
would like you know heal some of the
damage
and so i have this vision and i have no
idea how we're going to get it done
but we need a body of people
and i think it's going to be people
actually that other people
actually trust
like and if you try to imagine and this
is something i'd love for
everyone listening to this to do because
i i do this every once in a while
and unfortunately it's getting worse who
are these people yeah who are these
people who are the most
trusted figures in american life
today who's your top draft pick
you know i i the first name that came to
mind for me is uh
still barack obama i think he'd be on
the list i would have picked oprah
she's a number i would have nominated
oprah's on the list uh i agree so this
is something that i i
uh i think would be necessary to bring
us back from the brink is that you have
folks who just people believe and
believe in
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by helix sleep
what i love about helix sleep is that
you can get yourself a mattress
for not just yourself or whoever your
partner is whatever you're sharing the
bed with whether it's pets or kids or
partners
you can find the right mattress for you
so helix weep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to find the perfect mattress
for you so if you like a softer firm
or you sleep on your side or your back
or your stomach or you sleep hot
you can do a whole bunch of things with
helix so i took the quiz
i got the lux model i got the biggest
one i could find and it's
the right kind of softness i love it so
here's the deal just go to
helixsleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you with a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your life
and i mean that best leave your life
sleep like a baby helix right now
is offering 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows
for our yang speak listeners at
yang that's helix h-e-l-i-x-sleep.com
for up to 200 off and two free pillows
andrew what is your middle name i really
want to clarify this
in the worst way i do not have a middle
name
uh the the internet has sometimes given
me one
but i do not have a legal middle name i
eventually asked my parents hey i don't
have a middle name why is that and my
mom said
because we wanted you to choose one i
never did actually choose one
and so it's andrew yang legally
everything else is just uh you know made
made-up thing
so if you have the power to control
andrew yang's wikipedia page it says
andrew m yang
that is [ __ ] we don't know where the
m came from do we know what that m
stands for
i thought i thought it was middle name
man i literally think that someone
andrew the man
took middle name and took it down they
got a good photo of you on here man
really good photo thank you thank you
wikipedia photo
chooser elin adler asks what ended up
happening with the ted cruz basketball
game before you answer i'm happy to say
that ted cruz has gotten
more hateable since he dropped the ball
in this basketball game which i didn't
think was possible
okay go ahead i think most people know
this so um
ted cruz said something on twitter and
then i said ted i'd be happy to defeat
you in basketball and he said bring it
on
and then i said great and then i said
let's do it
and then uh radio silence and i did hear
through someone who knew someone that
they eventually came to the opinion that
playing me was a bad idea
um that they they thought he would lose
um and so uh so i will share the story
that i might entertain people
so shortly after this challenge was
accepted by ted cruz
i went on jimmy kimmel's show and i
don't know if you remember jimmy kimmel
played ted cruz for charity once
in uh i think in houston painful
basketball game to watch
and so then i asked uh jimmy i was like
hey jimmy i want to play
play ted cruz and basketball for charity
very soon you have any guidance for me
and then he like you know
said to me he was like he grabs he holds
he he's like
this freaking guy
so anyway that was the scouting report
from jimmy
uh but it was literally he just like
went radio silent and no showed and then
just uh
you know and his staff apparently
decided it was a bad
value prop for them i really would have
enjoyed that game
i think i would have won a lot of one
who would run around him
and women we will raise money for
charity we've been great data is a
proper right i haven't talked about it a
lot
um or a lot recently but you talk about
it a lot
anything exciting you in that realm or
thoughts there i did speak to some folks
who were
advising the new york state legislature
about
this issue and they were studying the
law in california
so that would be great news so
most of you know that the cpra in
california passed
this past november and it's only been
six months so there haven't been massive
moves
uh since then but the fact that new york
is studying is a very big deal because i
think that if new york were to adopt
some version of enhanced data protection
like that
shows that our data is ours and our
property
that would be very very powerful i think
that if you've got california and new
york
that the feds may follow and that you
might have a national framework
so that's my exciting update on data as
a property right is that
it that the california victory is having
ripple effects in other parts of the
country and i guarantee you that new
york is not the only state that's
looking at it
mark munoz 23 on twitter said what would
you say to someone wanting to run for
congress but has no
idea where to start
well mark uh what what a great question
and i
i say uh i actually write a chapter
about this
in my book that's upcoming there are
books out there that talk about like
the right way to run for congress um
you know um but uh in my opinion there
may not be any right way to run for
congress there are a number of people
who supported the presidential campaign
who decided to take the plunge
here on yank speaks we recently talked
to two of them wendy hamilton erica
rhodes
and they had some background of activism
i think it's a real act of courage uh
and vision for both of them
so mark there are resources that will
tell you the right way uh you know
one thing to do is to get involved with
local politics another thing is just to
try and take it on um and see what you
can
do uh blair walsingham is another person
that comes to mind for me she eventually
raised
over a hundred thousand dollars and
became the democratic nominee
um in her district in in tennessee the
first thing i'd ask you is why you want
to do it
um you have a really powerful reason to
run and
if that powerful reason is something
where andrew has like i think we need to
rewrite the rules the economy then you
should shoot for the moon if there's
like an awareness thing or that sort of
thing but if it's
mainly which is a lot of people running
is like i think i would be better at
this than most people because i'm a good
person i'm well read i'm
articulate passionate like people then
you gotta find the right race to run in
um and sometimes it's starting local and
like building up slowly um and you can
stay at those
offices for like short periods of time
you're not talking about you know
waiting your time on a bench for years
and years and years
um but the reality is you have to raise
a bunch of money so you got to look and
see who can
who can actually who in my network who
are my friends and friends who in the
democratic party would actually be open
to
giving me ten twenty hundred thousand
whatever yeah
or or another party um and sorry or
republican yeah yeah
the rule of thumb uh for a congressional
campaign
um is to imagine that you have to raise
three hundred thousand dollars
in order to run in like a normal
district
um which is frankly well beyond the
reach of like the vast majority of
humans
uh in in this country i mean you know
like like who's gonna
and it it's not like you can have a rich
uncle just give you 300k
either i mean there's going to be a
contribution like
a ton of people yeah so uh so mark that
that that is the rule of thumb or the
conventional wisdom i i will say that
sometimes [ __ ] the conventional wisdom i
mean who cares but that that is
something that
um you know the the quote-unquote
experts uh
said as a benchmark the problem with
politics one of it like it gets easier
the longer you do it
they get you know so if you've been if
you're if you're a state rep
then it's easier to run for congress and
if you're congress it's easier to run
for center like people
the establishment it's an institution
right it's like finance it's like
insurance it's a there's a whole
machinery around it
now that said i'm with andrew sometimes
just gotta blow the whole thing up which
we did
i think i would say this if you feel it
in your heart you should do it um and
it's hard but it's super rewarding most
people will talk about it done it like
it's frustrating if you don't win
um but i know a lot of people who ran
and did not win
and uh they almost always grew a ton as
a result
and and i think that's true for people
who run for lots of different offices so
i'd encourage you to run mark um and if
not for congress maybe for something
else like i
genuinely think it'll make you a
bigger person certainly i grew a ton
you know running for office and i would
be here
hanging talking to zach and all of you
right now that's for sure
and the last question i see here is from
sunnyvale42
andrew if you could talk to your younger
self what would you say
zack let me hit you with that what would
you tell a young zach
i would tell me to take more risk like i
wish i had jumped on an andrew yang
bandwagon
or plan earlier um because i think
i think we're all in these you're in
this like we're all in these
whether it's lanes for some people where
it's like you go middle school and high
school and college
for some or it's like you feel like
you're trapped in this and i think
um if you can take a crazy risk or get
off that beaten path
um you should um because we need people
that's where all the
that's where all the fun stuff happened
because everybody and their mother said
andrew you should not run for president
you have no reason doing it
everybody there's not one per there's
like you know a small handful of people
that said go ahead and do it but the
vast majority were like you're effing
nuts
and it was the right decision
fold right um so i wish to me i wish i'd
like learn to think outside the box a
little differently and
try and get off that path sooner so
that's what i would say um
but in one ways i wouldn't want to
change it because i ended up where i am
i work with you so
oh well thank you zach that means a ton
to me man i i'm
i'm so like thrilled and proud uh
that you and i work together like it's
it's really an honor to to be able to
work with you
brother what would you say to your young
self for me i know
it would be the advice that i probably
could not never
follow um which is just to try and take
it easier on myself when i was younger
when i was younger i was always so
brought up and caught up and just like
down on myself because like i
you know didn't do enough wasn't uh
good enough and whatever it was um
and or like uh
you know women didn't like me or call me
back and it would
like you know make me sad for days and
days and days just like if i could tell
myself just like man just
you know be at ease like things end up
working out for you in ways that you
can't imagine
like it's good to try and genuinely like
enjoy yourself in these moments but i
was very bad at that when i was younger
i
really wasn't terribly
at ease or laid back about what my
present or future held and i always felt
like i needed to be
doing something more uh yeah that there
wasn't
as much joy as there could have been
when i was young um
i had this strange exercise act that
happens to me now where
i i'm trying to go to sleep and maybe i
can't sleep at night
or at least easily i sleep quite well
just everyone knows but but like maybe
you know there's like
there are a few minutes when when like
you're having a hard time getting to
sleep
and i start counting um just one two
three four five and then each number i
try and remember something from that
year of my life
so obviously i can't remember anything
like one two three and then four i start
remembering something five
and i'm not remembering anything
specific it's like an image or a flash
or an emotion
uh and then i just keep going five six
seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve
uh and uh you know and and then
eventually i'm getting into you know
like 25
30 30 i don't like remembering like you
know who i was and
at least maybe like a moment of
something i experienced uh during that
year of my life
uh and then by the time i get to 46
which is what i am now
um you know i'm sort of like in the
present and somehow it relaxes me
somehow like imagining this arc
of like you know like like the the years
of my life like you know
that then i kind of feel more at rest
but if you looked at like
the way i was in year 24
25 26 27 i was like always so
tense and uh um
trying to figure it out uh you know
trying to make progress
a lot of the times when i couldn't make
progress i would just do something that
gave me a feeling of progress
that you can control so like the basic
one during those years for me was going
to the gym it's like well like you know
maybe
uh you know maybe relationships aren't
exactly materialized in the way i want
or maybe my career is not going the way
i want but
i can pump this iron max today yeah
yeah like i could do that um
and uh you know and you can argue
whether that was like a healthier uh
unhealthy way to channel that feeling
but i had that feeling
my entire uh um
20s i'd say um i met evelyn when i was
31
and i thank goodness that i didn't meet
her until then because i
just started to mellow out enough so
that
when you know she met me that i could i
i could
like be someone that frankly you could
build like a healthy long-term
relationship with
and if she had met me at any other point
i she like would not have
we would not be married today like i i i
know this 100
in part zach um because i don't know
people know this but so i
like start you know going out with
evelyn um
and then uh after like a few dates um
she writes me an email
and says like hey i don't think we
should see each other anymore um
and uh and then i take this email
and like i'm saddened obviously um but
then i genuinely
write her back about how like yeah you
know i totally understand you should
like
um go uh like enjoy yourself and like
you know have great experiences because
she'd come out of like a
long-term relationship at that point and
so she wrote me being like essentially
like i'm not ready to actually date
um and so i said like yeah like totally
get it like you know like uh
like i want you to um um to go do
like uh whatever it is that you know you
wish you'd been doing this past period
of months and i hit send on this email
and then i genuinely like sat down on my
couch was like okay i'm never gonna see
her again and that was very sad but like
i was actually able to accept it
and i would never have been able to
accept it in any kind of like
even moderately healthy way when i was
29 28 27 like i would have been like
completely
keyed up and then if i had written her
back and like
it would have come through like how
wounded i was
um but because i was like at least
somewhat at peace with it
um at the age of 31 she then called me
like a couple days later and was like
hey what are you doing you want to like
obviously it would like mystified me
completely because i was like i thought
i was not too yeah we just broke out
yeah you see you again
but i am free and so i just you know
went to where they were
and then the next night i would like say
like the same thing happened several
nights in a row where it was like hey
what are you doing
hey what are you doing and then each
time even after i'd go out and hang out
with her and her friend somewhere
i'd be like and never going to see her
again and like it just happened several
times
right so um
you know so i would try and go back in
time and tell myself to relax
but i you know i just wasn't capable of
it at that point so if you're young and
you can relate to that
um just so you know you do mellow out at
least i did
i i think you're like a relatively
intense guy in like a
i'm in a productive way so i'm curious
to think of
curious to imagine what intense andrew
is
like younger andrew um how much of a
workhorse you probably were
that's what you're talking about but um
your answer made me
rethink mine is like honest like as a
kid you
i wish i knew uh not to care what other
people think so much
you know there's a dr seuss other quotes
like uh
be you are say we feel i think because
those who mind don't matter and those
who matter don't mind
and it's like if you can't be yourself
you don't want to be around those people
if people don't like you for who you are
you don't want to be around them anyway
um i wish i knew that at a younger age i
kind of learned that in college and look
weren't for that email man
who would be here for sure i i genuinely
have
i was like i really should just like uh
be be thanking uh my lucky stars
for whatever i put in that email because
like who knew
that's your angel got in your hand man
anyway guys
thank you for tuning into our mailbag
we'll try and do a little more often if
we can the schedules are good thank you
thank you thank you
for uh being here for me and zach and
the podcast and supporting us it means
the world to both of us
uh i'm so thrilled that we got to this
hundredth episode celebration
uh here's to 100 more than 100 more
after that
because this this podcast is really
special to me and important to me like
it's something that
uh i value um you know
just because it's like uh like it
enables me to
um think and process and interact and
socialize sometimes in like a particular
way like i
i'm i'm so grateful and we couldn't do
this without everyone listening to this
right now so i just want to say thank
you from the bottom of my heart
amen and on a fun note uh fact check
pete booty judge's dad
is from malta well done andrew as usual
spot on remembering that type of fact
[Music]
you